pénurie de masques maintien des
élections municipales ou encore absence
de lisibilité quant à l'action
gouvernementale pour la première fois
edouard philippe va devoir s'expliquer
devant les parlementaires quant à sa
gestion de cette crise sanitaire ce
témoignage a très attendue devrait
permettre d'apporter un éclairage quant
au contexte mais aussi au timing des
décisions prises lorsqu'il était en
fonction
cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire qui a commencé ses travaux
en juin dernier aura de nombreuses
questions à poser à l'ancien premier
ministre
la gestion des stocks de masques la
stratégie en matière de tests la prise
en charge des résidents en état d' le
nom report du premier tour des élections
municipales ou encore les conséquences
économiques et budgétaires de la crise
sanitaire
il faut dire qu'il doit re philippe et
son gouvernement ont enchaîné les
maladresses aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
indication acheter des masques le port
du masque en population générale dans la
rue ça ne sert à rien je pourrais dire
je suis mini je me mets un masque en
fait je sais pas l'utiliser cette
audition intervient alors que le
domicile et le bureau du maire du havre
comme celui d'anciens membres du
gouvernement ont été perquisitionnés
dans le cadre d'une information
judiciaire ouverte par la cour de
justice de la république
les plaignants dénoncent entre autres
l'incohérence des mesures prises au
sommet de l'état et l'absence
d'application des recommandations de
l'om est ce une procédure qui ne semble
pas inquiéter outre mesure l'ex premier
ministre cette perquisition s'est
déroulée dans les conditions normales à
la fois avec beaucoup de minutie de la
part de ceux qui procédait dans une
atmosphère poli et courtoise
la justice est saisie elle travaille
sereinement moi aussi mais attention
décontraction ne veut pas dire
insouciance cette première audition
edouard philippe la prépare
d'arrache-pied à l'ancien premier
ministre c'est que chaque mot compte
il a notamment revu toute la chronologie
des événements avec ses principaux
collaborateurs
edouard philippe qui toujours d'après
son entourage n'hésitera pas à pointer
les divisions
au sein du corps médical mais également
en mettant en avant les revirements de
l' oms et c'est l'ensemble de l'exécutif
qui fait face à des critiques quant à
son manque de préparation et même
d'anticipation dans cette crise
sanitaire
après l'ex premier ministre ce sera au
tour de l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner d'être entendu par
les députés puis le 27 octobre prochain
ce sera au tour du ministre de la santé
de se présenter ici à l'assemblée
nationale